-We're hanging out
with Will Arnett,
and we're about to play a game
called "Hey Robot."
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, robot ♪
♪ Hey, robot ♪
-All right. So here's the deal.
This is based
on a real board game, okay?
Well, this is like
your classic game Password,
but your partner
is a smart speaker.
All right? So I'll pick a card
with a word on it.
Then we'll take turns asking
a question to get the speaker
to say the words
somewhere in its answer.
All right? All right.
If it does, we get a point.
Here we go. I will --
I will go first.
All right. "Corn dog."
"Corn dog" is the word.
-Corn dog.
Gosh.
Alexa, what do you call
a hot dog dipped in batter?
-Here's something
I found on the Web.
According to Wikipedia.org,
if served with a stick,
it is referred to as a hot dog
and usually dipped
in a generous amount
of tomato sauce and consumed...
-All right. Alexa, stop.
You're embarrassing yourself.
What is she talking about?
Yeah, that's what I said.
I said hot dog
dipped in -- Whatever.
This is your turn.
You talk to the thing.
I can't even do it.
-Hey, man, take it easy.
-Nah, nah, nah. You know what?
We can cut the whole thing out.
-No, Jimmy,
we're not gonna cut --
Hey, no, you did great.
You did great.
-Are we done?
-No.
And I want you to know
the term "hero"...
No, Jimmy. Sit down.
[ Microphone crackling ]
The term "hero" gets thrown
around a lot these days, but --
[ Laughter ]
That was the worst
faking to take off a mic.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. All right.
[ Both exhale sharply ]
Now, do I have to
do this word, too?
-Yes.
-Okay.
Hey, Siri.
-No. It's the other one.
It's the other one.
-What is it?
-A-L-E-X-A.
-Okay. Yeah.
-Hey, Bing, what --
-[ Laughs ] Gosh.
-Okay. I got it.
I got it. Here we go.
I got it. I got it.
Let's do it for real.
Come on.
Let's stop messing around.
Come on. Grow up.
-Let's stop having fun, please.
-Hey, Alexa,
where do you get off?
-Come on. Alexa, stop.
Don't listen to him.
You don't have to
listen to this. Let's go.
-All right.
We'll skip to the next one.
Let's skip to the next one.
All right.
Tie score -- 100 to 100.
Here we go.
-Jason Bateman. Okay.
-Alexa, who stars
in the show "Ozark"?
-"Ozark" stars
include Jason Bateman...
[ Bell dings ]
...and Sofia Hublitz.
-All right. Alexa, stop.
That was more than enough.
Thank you.
Will, it's your turn to match
and try to beat me here.
The word is "bald."
-Alexa, what kind of eagle
is almost extinct?
-Here's something I found
from the article
"White-tailed eagle"
on Wikipedia.
Ultimately,
the white-tailed eagle
was almost extinct in Europe,
extirpated
from all but Scandinavia
and some sparse patches
of Eastern Europe.
-Oh, Alexa. Give it a rest.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
Let me try to see
if I can get this one here.
Uh, um...
Alexa, what is Rogaine for?
-According to First Databank,
Rogaine Extra Strength for Men
is a brand-name drug
whose generic name
is minoxidil.
Rogaine Extra Strength for Men
is classified
as the hair-growth medications
and hypertrichotic medications,
according to Wikipedia.
Rogaine Extra Strength for Men
is used to treat hyper...
-All right. Alexa, stop.
I'm not doing a whole commercial
for -- Geez.
-Let me -- let me --
Let me try one more...
-Alexa, stop. Alexa, stop.
-I got one more in me.
-Go.
-Alexa, how would you describe
the look of Daddy Warbucks?
-Sorry. I'm not sure about that.
-Yeah, me neither.
I'm not, either.
That makes two of us. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I'd say -- I'd say maybe aloof?
-He was aloof.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man. All right. Last one.
-What was the plot
of that movie?
I forget. Anyway,
we'll talk about it later.
-The last one. Whoever gets
this wins the whole thing.
Ready?
-Ohh.
-Will, you can go first.
-[ Sighs ]
Alexa...
what is the signature move
in karate?
-Here's something I found
on reference.com.
Karate has many basic moves
that are classified
as offensive or defensive.
While there are many
different styles of karate,
basic moves such
as the forearm block
and straight punch
are common to most forms.
-Thank you. Perfect.
-What?!
-Well said. Well said. I agree.
All right. Let me try.
-Okay. Go.
-Alexa,
name different cuts of pork.
-According to an
Alexa Answers contributor,
there are nine main beef cuts.
They are chuck, rib, loin,
round, flank,
short plate, brisket,
and shank.
-You just named
the Eight Stooges.
I hated Shank.
He was my least favorite.
[ Laughter ]
I never liked Shank.
I like all the other Stooges.
All right. I think
that's the game right there.
I'm gonna give it to you.
My guest, Will Arnett.
Congratulations.
You are the champ.
[ Bell dinging ]
-We were terrible at that.
-Terrible.
-There's no celebrating
here today, Jimmy.
-Will Arnett.
His podcast, "Smartless,"
is available every Monday.
And his animated show,
"Your Daily Horoscope,"
is available five days a week
on Quibi.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Thanks for coming on, Will.